ready for this yes sir
and it will kill
partisan my name is Philip shry I'm 36
years old I'm from Spring Texas what I
love the most about bladesmithing is the
passion behind it being able to create
something that comes from the heart and
then seeing my daughter who's about four
taking pride in what Daddy just did
knowing that that's pretty cool and
she's molding her mind and she can do it
in the future one day too
partisan was a late Renaissance Era pole
arm used by European armies up until the
early 19th century
roughly six feet long partisans featured
a large Blade with a strong medial Ridge
and razor edge making it as lethal a
slasher as it was a Thruster
the weapon also contained two upturn
branches flared from the base of the
blade which helped the user parry and
even control an opponent's weapon at a
distance
with the onset of firearms pole arms
lost practical use and mostly
disappeared from combat
however the partisan lives on today as
an ornate ceremonial weapon
in his standard fashion for the Yeoman
of the Guard the bodyguards to the
British monarchs
the pure sword
I'm Davey Wilson I'm 49 years old and
I'm a master Barber unfortunately I'm
losing the master Barber's hair on top
of my head my dad and I took class
together and after we built our very
first knife I looked over and I said hey
you want to build another one he said I
sure do part of the reason I am here now
is to make Dad proud featured in season
7 of Fortune fire the PIRA is an ornate
versatile sword used by the Yukon tribe
in the southern Philippines the weapon's
unique blade sheet and long pommel
proved to be challenging for both Smiths
who were ultimately forced to start over
the third day of their builds ultimately
once myth was unable to secure the
mechanical connection to her handle in
time forcing the judges to issue a vote
of no confidence due to safety concerns
the main thing I want to get
accomplished today is forging out that
socket if I don't get that done that's
going to put me behind where I need to
be for tomorrow
for the blade I'm I'm starting out with
a good chunk of sheet steel 1095 high
carbon there we go Smith's have been
making medial ridges for hundreds if not
thousands of years but when all of my
research that I found I could not find
how they traditionally put mebular
ridges on blades that were so pronounced
so I'm really having to go just a little
different route than I think what is
traditionally done
I'm going to take bar stock tack weld it
throw it in the Forge Forge weld it
throw a bead of weld and then I'm gonna
go in and clean up those welds so I get
those really drastic curves
the weight of the piece is going to be
heavier but I'm going to have structural
Integrity that is sufficiently ground I
think we are ready to heat treats
I think we are good
just going to kind of do a dry fit and
see where I'm at with the
hole here not going to peen it I still
need to take it all apart for some more
work but just getting that step in the
process done and ready to move forward
with it
whoops
I'm thinking no it'll come right off no
problem
I was wrong
it's like why am I taking this out if it
fits so well but to keep working on it I
need it out
wow I'm an idiot
that's not budging
I can't get it off
if I can't pull that off I don't know
what I'm going to do
a budget as I'm prying on this Vice
trying to get the bar
out burn the wood it'll come right out
voila
disaster averted
of all the things to go wrong right a
major build ten thousand dollars on the
line he prematurely gets his wooden
staff stuck in it
so I'm not planning on testing right now
if it's gonna malfunction if it's gonna
break at this point I want the judges to
have the honor of destroying something
that I've built not me I think that
feels good
today we're here in beautiful Branson
Missouri I'm tasked with making the PIRA
the handle will probably be the most
challenging part of this build
well hey Dan hey had a visitor this
morning just about to get started on
this sword anytime in the past when Dad
would stop in he'd jump right in and
help me with the knife build I don't
know if he was disappointed or relieved
that he didn't have to help with this
build
I'd like to help on something like that
but at least it's a shorter one that's
right it's different than anything we've
done before all right see ya
feels good I believe that he's going to
be extremely proud of how this blade
performs I believe we got a good
straight blade
I'm having trouble just getting this
Walnut cut through having to use some
chisels sometimes it needs a little
persuasion
finally it worked
once we epoxy and pin the blade to the
handle it's going to be one homogeneous
piece looking good it's holding there
I've got the handle to a comfortable
point now it's time to test it's pretty
sharp but it's not not where it needs to
be for my first Pier I'm pretty happy
with it please fits this is the kill
test
tessell lethality of your weapon I will
deliver killing blows in this ballistics
dummy fill your purse you ready for this
yes sir man let's do it going into this
test my heart's starting to pump a
little faster Doug's hopefully just
going to destroy this ballistics dummy
foreign
Phil the design you have here is scary
that's a very thick spine you have it
the edges are sharp as you can see very
deadly
the one thing about this is that
it's heavy that is something to take
into account when you're carrying
something like this into battle and you
gotta move multiple times but more
importantly pure weapon
will kill
thank you sir all right Davey are you
set sir you're next yes sir
all right Dave let's talk about the
Arpita sword here first up in your
design it's a very forward heavy weapon
as you can see just by looking at the
spine it's thick here and it tapers down
to the guard now your Edge is sharp with
a forward weight it chops into the big
carcass but slicing not quite because
you have to control the weight of the
weapon but
it will kill yeah I will
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pike push and armor
stab
now the partisan was often used in
Castle or in city defense so to test the
overall strength and construction of
your blades I'll be pushing against
these pipes with the blade and then
stabbing into the armor now this test is
not about what your weapons do to the
targets spell those targets you're going
to do to your weapons
Philip you're up first you ready yes sir
[Music]
thank you
all right Philip this thing is a beast
the weight the shape of your tip really
makes it a good penetrating weapon the
issue I have as a partisan was a
standoff weapon got to be able to
control it and at full extension that
weight's hard to control
I like the fact that you have this High
medial Ridge I like your design my only
issue is the white good job thank you
sir Davey your blade has to survive one
strike on this brutal test and if you do
you win Dave
all right Davey man there's a lot of
weapon here your grinds are beautiful I
think your handle is beautiful and
comfortable
there's no end to damage on this at all
awesome I would not run my finger down
this blade
you nailed the heat treat on that good
job thank you
forged in fire war of weapons